well days and gentlemen is Wednesday and
we've got former SEAL Team six member
current current squirrel suit record
holder jumping off of cliffs in
Switzerland at all and Navy SEAL
foundation money raiser and all-around
good looking kid and I say kid because
he's a lot younger I feel safe in it
yeah he's got a barrel chest barrel
chest and keeps his hair short nowadays
Andy stumps I was calling you sit on
denture like that for everybody yeah
it's a little dark a little bit over
this too much right yes too much much ah
are you uh are you jumping a lot lately
given the weather over the last week
I've actually been pinned to the ground
I actually have three brand new wing
suits that have been staring at me in my
house and just low clouds one of those
who makes those Wing suits is they're
actually called squirrel suits like most
people see them and they're like oh it's
a squirrel suit there's a there's
actually a brand that if you have to pay
for more do they send them to you
because you're batshit crazy well first
because if they send in my bat you know
I just say no no no life ain't crazy I
mean you're crazy enough you have the
balls enough to jump off a building with
squirrels like we yeah no you pay for
him but I'm very fortunate to have some
sponsors so it's kind of a path tree
cost how much would a suit like that
cost if I want to jump off I don't know
fully logo tout suit you're going to run
you about 2,600 bucks Wow jeepers LaVon
yeah it's desirable kids going huh the
barriers to entry you actually it's a
problem people see stuff on YouTube and
there really is no mechanism to stop you
from buying everything that I use to
jump off of stuff it would show up at
your house and if you could figure out
how to put it together and put the stuff
on I mean there's nobody stopping you
you told me you tell me that in
Switzerland and I don't know if this I
misread what you said that in - we in a
two-week period misheard in a two-week
period of people were jumping off the
cliffs you were jumping off of and in a
two-week period how many people were
killed so my last trip to Switzerland
was I think it was late July early
August of last year I try to go at least
once a year for two two and a half weeks
because there's so much stuff to do yeah
but in the lauterbrunnen valley which is
like the mecca
base-jumping because it's so accessible
each side of the valley there's trains
and cable cars and you can do some
hiking stuff but it's just it's
constantly active all day every day in a
14 day two week time period 14
fatalities 14 fatalities you know I mean
many people bring that up what is the
what it's a tough one to guess I would
say there was probably 150 active
jumpers in the valley but a lot of it's
a lot but you know there also hasn't
been an incident report that has
surprised me in a couple of years like
you see what people are attempting to do
you guys always trying to one-up each
other's that why doesn't surprise you uh
I wouldn't say that I mean I don't
consider myself inside that community
but the people who are trying to push
the leading edge forward and forward and
forward yes they are in that so get a
crack a few eggs to make an omelet so
there's a so probably one of the most
famous proximity wingsuit flyers these
guys are flying really close to the
ground his name is Graham Dixon or
Graham Dickerson he died a couple months
ago in China attempting something that
if you look at the math of what he would
have been required to do glide
percentage glide ratio wise it was not
feasible that's what was he thinking he
was thinking that he needed to continue
to push himself to constantly be on the
leading edge team daredevil died in
August alone with one jump posting term
proposing footage of his death Facebook
live is booked Kylie I feel like it's
awesome you know that video is awesome
well the cows that all the cows over
there have bells so actually I'll
probably probably gonna be people
Anatomy that I said it was awesome but
so I'll resent metal so it was really
awesome
- is that the video no those are the
guys who jumped off the Burj Al Khalifa
that's Fred and Vince they're amazing so
I thought so they read envision this
dude in them jump so this guy's a
wingsuit on Facebook life puts his phone
inside of an internal pocket jumps off
impacts you hear the last minutes of
life there's usually some gurgling some
breath and then it becomes very quiet
and a lot of the animals in Switzerland
had these huge cow bells on them and
then tell you right here I've been there
too like ding ding ding oh my god Erie
now I'm assuming they died instantly
no sometimes this gut woman
his met his brain might have been dead
but the body fights it oh yeah for a
little bit uh there was a couple guys
who went in a few years ago I mean so in
a wingsuit you're travelling forward I
can do 120 130 140 miles an hour forward
with a fall rate that can maybe I could
lower it to I can actually gain altitude
now in the new suits for a little bit
and then obviously you would fall to the
sky but you're coming down and maybe
you're only falling it's 30 miles an
hour
so there have been a few people that
they basically skip they find themselves
over flatter terrain than they can
outfly and they'll skip in a guy a few
years ago I think lived about two weeks
in the hospital a buddy of mine went in
in France you guys want to watch an
awesome video buddy mind winning in
France and lived was found three hours
later by hikers yelling and moaning in
his wingsuit you have the video here on
YouTube he was recalled giving you a go
to Eric dos Santos just Eric dos Santos
trees yeah so crazy crash there you go
that'll do it and and hit you've got to
see it there it is and I can die and I
freaked out I can't handle it so this is
a strategist Chaminade amazing exit you
jump this I haven't I want to of course
you do
oh that's doing in the world right there
okay so he's falling now he's flying and
I think they're going to speed up this
video here a little bit because it's
quite a long flight you make this
right-hand turn around these rocks
that's so crazy
that's so crazy already so that enough
adult would be a great flight but this
terrain allows you to come down here I
know do but pull shoot pull shoot please
now doesn't he know hello I'm so nervous
I get so nervous are there any weight
could be a lesson almost evening I get
so nervous with this [ __ ] god dammit you
can see he's not he's lower than the
trees Andy and he's flying very slow
that's what almost killed him so so for
me watching this video about 30 seconds
ago I could tell something was wrong
he's it only he's going too slow he's
why only would he swatch this so he's
stalling the suit out no fascination huh
that's an issue
shut it ah that's not good if you're not
good he lived he lived I saw him at the
drop zone like a month ago he's talking
about what's out there he was on
Facebook the other day like hey is
anybody
a parachute that I can borrow and like
no I don't I don't have a parachute you
can borrow that's not been laid we
Russian Roulette had the gun go off and
he lived yeah
it's shot in the face basically that's
what happened and he survived he flew
his wingsuit into the trees in full
flight and he lived in your film that
sound your ability to some do solo yeah
yeah he's an interesting cat yeah he's a
black guy yeah
doctor is there a lot of black guys that
jump out of the sky let me ask the
question I don't know matter that I
don't know the stats
well you're around a couple have you
yeah I mean I wouldn't say that any
notion I'd say a lot of black guy jumper
swimming that's fair to say
Brennan a little stereo sighs I I think
so ABS they don't qualify as a
stereotype but you don't see a wallet
like ready to sit there smiling you
don't see a lot of black guys on the top
of Mount Everest no right or I'm K to
know is they not yet a black sport this
is what that I what yellow like money
often climb it all the way up step [ __ ]
amount for no real for what if they did
we'd all be photo I can fall into a
mile-deep Craig if they're faster than
anyone yeah so yeah 14 people most of
them flying wing suits had something
like that happen but didn't survive see
all miscalculation but you can sail
right away you're a cigarette is head
right some of it is miscalculation some
of it is people who are so far above
their experience level and had just have
no respect for the margins or the
boundaries or their own experience doing
it's right here done well yeah there was
a guy who on his like when you put a
wing BASE jumping in and of itself
without a wingsuit on is high
consequence you have one parachute you
need if something goes wrong you're
going to have issues and you need to
have control of your parachute control
your body then you throw on the cross
between a prom dress and a straitjacket
right you get a squirrel suit on and you
jump off and your mobility is restricted
you have a lot more speed and you still
only have one parachute and you need to
like start off on a jump that's not
technically complex you know maybe a
crawl walk run theory yeah would serve
you well if you want to actually extend
your lifespan in the sport beyond you
know a few seconds some people skip that
but like no I'm just going to throw a
wingsuit on this is a moderately
technical jump we may go in
I don't surprises no kind of it that's
kind of a that's kind of stupidity I
mean it get up humans in general yeah I
think everyone wants they see it on
YouTube now like I can do it you know
that TV if I can jump here what's the
difference jump here and you've had how
many hours of jumps where you have as a
seal you're jumping out of planes and
you're flying you've learned how to fly
from way before you start doing squirrel
I didn't put a wingsuit on until I had
about 3,500 jumps and in those 3,500
think about how many that is first of
all well in the minimum required for
there's a the governing body of
skydiving in the US as the u.s. PA at
the United States parachute Association
and they have some guidelines and their
guideline is and this is ridiculous no
wings who jumps until you have 200 jumps
but then beyond that point it's fair
game and you see people who come to the
drop zone and I've seen this happen
multiple times here I'm talking I just
saw this crazy YouTube video this guy's
wine the squirrel suit how do I get into
a wingsuit as fast as humanly possible
so they come they're expressing the goal
that they just want to get through the
200 jumps to put a wing suit on and then
they just want to learn how to base show
up and go combine the two and then when
they die it's like you know this is my
not surprised face or she died and if
this is my not surprised you seem at the
drop zone and they're like oh hey we
jump with me like no I'm not going to be
involved with in any way shape or form
or having a relationship with you
because I think what you're doing is
stupid and you're not long for this
world
and you're gonna die and I'll tell them
exactly this I'm like your approach is
incorrect you're diving headlong into
something you don't understand you're
going to end up dying and I want
anything to do with it so no come on
baby is there a lot of like Special
Forces guys like yourself who are doing
similar stuff or so like kind of chase
in that kind of adrenaline rush because
that does that you're all seeing a
drowing junk yeah I think that's fair to
say how dare you I think I would not
alright I don't jump for the I don't get
adrenaline like when I skydive at all
it's actually I'm usually asleep on the
plane on the way up
BASE jumping certainly wakes me up and
I'm alive and I'm in that moment but I
don't I don't I'm not seeking the
adrenaline aspect of it I like the
challenge of it but I would say that you
know that hyper where hyper acute
sensation that most people associate
with adrenaline is not the driving cause
and it for me then what is it just
couldn't you forget that if it's not a
gentleman couldn't you do ultramarathons
or an obvious baby lighting campaign so
you know I'm saying I'm Sam Mars Moreira
right it's I mean if you do it right
just then what you're doing it is hard
to describe so I love the sensation of
flying but like it feels like it every
picture of me jumping in a wingsuit I'm
smiling because you're flying through
the air at 120 miles an hour face-first
it's fun it's amazing and by the way
just over the treetops yeah
well that you sent me videos that I that
you're so close to the [ __ ] rocks
trees that I I keep watching them over
and over again cuz I let's freaks me out
it's just stupid yeah um so it feels
great but for me I mean honestly what I
get out of it is that that release from
all the other BS in my life and I think
I'm gonna talk to you guys a little bit
about this first time I was on like when
you have your toes on the edge of a
cliff
and you're in a wingsuit or even just
BASE jumping you got one parachute on
you are not thinking about did I
transfer money over to my checking
account to cover my mortgage you're not
thinking about an argument you might
have had with your spouse you're not
thinking about work you're in the zone
you are I mean I you literally most the
time you know you spit to check the wind
if you can get enough spit to form in
your mouth as you check the wind your
heart is racing you're scared out of
your mind and you you know and you have
a choice in that moment do you let the
fear control you or do you control the
fear and continue on with what it is you
want to do but that clarity in that
moment combined with how awesome the
flight feels is why I jump and then I
get by finding that moment and it's not
it's nothing new or unique to BASE
jumping there's books written about it's
the flow state right yeah and I used to
get it in helicopters overseas like one
minute alcohol from objective you're
going to get on
you're really not worried about anything
else in other words relation and you're
about to go good life in front of your
face is the only thing that matters and
for me I found that that reads like the
control-alt-delete for people who are
old enough to remember what that is you
know in a non-apple world it clears out
the hard drive and it lasts for months
after I do one of those Ritz
yeah it's wow so it's more the outlet
for me that's what I get out of it as a
person I truly think it makes me a
better father
it makes me it backs off and like it
makes me more compassionate I just have
more tolerance because it's that outlet
and I do you think it's a transition but
do you think it's your it's your way of
getting over because you and I've had
long conversations about you know combat
you know and and the kind of stuff that
you still deal with in that sense but
like do you think that that is your way
of dealing with sort of the withdrawal
from that heightened state of you know I
guess mental acuity when you're in a
combat situation because you you had to
have gotten they ought to talk about The
Hurt Locker a drug of war and [ __ ] where
you you you know like you said when
you're in a life in that fight I mean
and you're a competitive guy and the
stakes are life and death and you and
you win like you were pretty eloquent
about it you go it doesn't suck well no
you like killing people it's just like
it doesn't suck what are you on a
mission but also you get a high from it
right as far as it's you know you get a
objective you're there with your boys
you're doing it and then you get done
with that and you're back with civilian
life it was hard for people to being set
being successful overseas like targeting
an individual and then successfully
being able to prosecute and objective
that they're on capture or kill the
person it feels rewarding because you
feel like it makes a difference yeah I
don't think there's necessarily a high
that comes from that I think it's just a
sense of satisfaction you would be
amazed at the professionalism of the
guys that I used to work with it's not
it's not high-fives and chest bumps
there's not even a lot of talking we're
super quiet and we're super slow on
target and it's very methodical and
precise and purple it's almost like of
course we did this yeah that's you know
we do yes angular focus of your life
when you get to that point without
getting into medias with your when you
are call on mission so you get you get
coordinates on a phone probably sure I
mean that's certainly one way you could
do it okay write them and then you all
of you get the same information probably
on some kind of a phone or whatever so
you all convene right there's a full I
mean so again and this is why I hate
movies they set these totally
unrealistic expectations where
everything's constantly blowing up or
you know automatic weapons fire
everywhere
where's the 24 to 72 our planning cycle
and multiple briefs on the weather and
the objective and the insertion method
like that's what we spend most of our
time doing is planning preparation then
you go out and maybe in a career 1% of
your career would do the stuff that
makes it into movie somewhere yeah but
that's 99 percent of the movie it's just
a scale that is completely lopsided them
it's on his head yeah it yeah it's not a
zit it can be exciting
right but ya sitting there and I mean
you just go into a PowerPoint slide and
PowerPoint slide and powerpoints love
what seeing the there the objectives
like the perfect information you have I
mean it starts with the overarching
mission statement of how this objective
fits into the battle space commanders
overall plan for other executing war
right you can't just drop in and be like
hey we want to go after this guy you
have to justify it insides of the inside
of the line that the battlespace owner
has for that area and their objective if
it doesn't fit their objective they may
not let you do it
yeah so it's almost like you wants up to
get a warrant to do that right is police
work tough to get a warrant before they
it's a highly structured process behind
the scenes that's invisible to anybody
else and like I said it never shows up
in any of the mediums whether it be the
books the TV shows or the movies
surprise doesn't show up in the book the
movie makes a little bit boring it's
boring to read a PowerPoint slide it'd
be more boring to read about really
d-list information in there yeah kind of
details you d-did yeah man there we were
at Oh dark thirty reading about the
weather I'll take it I mean we have
slides on when the Sun is going to come
up when the moon is going to come on the
amount of illumination the weather what
a coordinated effort man well and that's
the other thing too like you look at if
you only focus on say you were able to
find a person that's one spoke on a
wheel
you had the intelligence community that
was helping you in bringing you
information you had the aviation assets
the mechanics I mean there's the people
who serviced the radios I mean it's like
the it's just it the movies are such a
thin wedge into the world that I mean it
and it's not their fault
overall yeah the movie heard for guys
like us who like to he looked alike yet
let's see me want to see them I want to
fighting moving on
I roll my eyes when you oh my god yes
have you ever seen a funny movie that
got anything right never never have you
ever seen a war movie that got a right
I've seen movies they get aspects of it
right like this is one of the best
opening sequences to a movie ever is
Saving Private Ryan verse 15 of that
movie d-day alarm money they capture
that you can't hear and all that chaos
the rain beige it but it just captures
the confusion and then Black Hawk Down
essence of that Saint kind of the same
thing it captures more of the chaos
because one of these are the 13th hour
with the Benghazi thing zero dark thirty
yes that that's pretty realistic isn't
it no okay uh but but like one of the
things that I maybe I told you this I
was doing a sketch for MADtv and the
stuntmen came in a shot was he's in a
room with full loads and they had a girl
like that blanks yes yeah and dude let
me tell you something it's so [ __ ]
loud of course not only was allowed but
they were smoke everywhere I couldn't
see anything
you're something I never thought about
so when they come into the room they go
like that it was like it was like you
guys we know what the [ __ ] Jesus yes and
then your ears ringing and you can't see
anything the whole room is for smoke do
you know Tim Kenny Allison you've talked
about I have met hit all of them you
know I've met him a couple times
okay yeah he he's interesting cuz he's
back in right he just I listed yeah
which is crazy because we're going to
Austin and I hey man gonna be op they'll
get you on the show and I don't hear
anything no anything let's get a picture
boom
and it's him just it's just a sleepy no
says whatever [ __ ] Force Ranger Kennedy
does sorry can't I was like good god
o'clock in man he's working yeah yeah
he's robbing I know he'll text me man if
you're a you know like you don't need a
lot you and I are talking and except
it's it's diet it's sensitive because we
were talking about we're really using a
lot of Special Forces guys and over the
past 13 years we killed a lot of people
and we've killed a lot of people with
teens and you know with drones yeah and
you know you really wonder after all of
this all due respect and we you not talk
is how effective has it been in the
overall objective of bringing peace to
that region or at least bringing a
government in that
that we can work with and the overall
stability of the Middle East and that's
got to be on your mind sometimes or
maybe you don't think about it you know
and I wonder if a guy thought your guys
job is it it becomes it later respect
you mean you have the rest of your life
to sit back and think about what I mean
I I think about it I don't know more or
less than other people but I spend a lot
of time thinking about it because I look
at my two sons one who's getting ready
to go into eighth grade and the other
one's just a year behind them and you
know what's it going to say in the
textbooks that they learn from what are
they going to get taught about the
places that I went and it in it for me
at least I spend a lot of time looking
in the rearview mirror which obviously
you have a lot better vision looking
back and trying to figure out whether or
not anything that I've ever done in my
career actually had any impact
whatsoever and for me the answer that I
come back to if I'm being totally honest
is probably not that's amazing then I
think the question is what kind of
impact were you looking for like do you
think yet you know I think the problem
itself is more complex than the solution
that we're throwing at it I think that
the problem that we're facing today is
never going to be solved by bombs and
bullets and now left on a SEAL Team six
however though we still have to do the
things that we're doing and the easiest
analogy that I can make for people is if
you're standing at a dam and there's
some water spurting out you're probably
better off plugging the holes that you
can to prevent yourself from drowning
over time as opposed to it letting it
get to a point where it's going to
catastrophic we break so that is the
role that I see the kinetic activity
overseas for the United States of
America is to plug as many holes as they
can and that does have an impact but
it's not going to have an impact on a
huge geopolitical level great and that's
a that's the most important thing
because bringing up that and being
honest with that is something that has
to be in the public dialog and it has
nothing to do with whether being
unpatriotic or supporting the troops I
[ __ ] hate when people talk that way
what it has to do with is if we can
learn from our past are we going to
learn from our history our recent
history in this case our current history
that we're living right now
and how do we avoid this in the future
is there a better tact and I don't know
the answers does your just the rest of
your team agree with that stay in sandy
have you guys talked about it I don't
know I mean I had no authority to speak
for anybody other than myself I think
some of the guys that I worked with are
very dedicated and would probably never
say that they don't think that what they
did I think that I had impact in
plugging the holes I don't think I said
save the dam from collapsing at some
point that I guess would be a better
articulate anyone save the dam move so
yeah somebody can save the dam but the
problem is I don't think it's the
Western world I don't think it's got to
be them it has to be them so if 1% of
Islam is considered radical and I'm
making that number up I have no idea
what the percentage are so let's say
let's say it's just 1% for either map
the Western world is never going to be
able to influence that 1% the only way
that problem is going to solve is it the
other 99% of the people get in and they
do something about it until then we are
in a position as a nation to provide
space for who we want to be that we have
to continue to strike when we see a
whole comment I couldn't agree more I
couldn't agree more with that and I
think that you just said create space
and I think that's where you guys come
in handy you know that was our job yeah
if you if you were to ask me at the end
of the day or today what I thought my
purpose was in the military it was to
create space for this country so that we
can exercise the freedoms that we have
you cannot exercise any freedom when you
have pressure on top of you so we all
know we all know there are people out
there that want to blow us to
smithereens
yes in fact and there there are
motivated people who are organized to do
that and that's when and when [ __ ]
happens you know what we all do is we go
guys like Andy and Tim Kennedy and those
guys are on it you know thank God thank
God because if we don't have the
sheepdogs keeping the wolves at bay and
it's just but you're always gonna the
way you read history it's always been or
when a country can do something to
another country they do it I mean it's
just it's just what happen beings are
like that towards each other because
what I've done why people and they're
always going to fight I mean once the
purpose of reality of it neva I mean
it's a super complex problem I mean it
and that's why a simple solution
which is you know kinetic actions in my
mind are relatively simple they don't
have any we're the new
answer complexity of diplomacy and the
type of nation interaction with nation
that would be required it like there's a
place for it but again it's a spoke on
the wheel there's got to be more than
just that do you know anything about
this so Trump is said to have released
highly classified information to the
Russian ambassador yeah do you know
anything about like if that do you have
any idea of what that is or if that's
like wow is that for a guy who is in a
position to rely on intelligence and
intelligence methodology and all that is
that potentially really something that
could get guys on the ground our guys
killed or I put in bad situation did he
put a spy in jeopardy but not one of the
American spies is another one right I
mean because like this conversation I
find myself paying attention to
absolutely nothing that happens at that
level because like where did you hear
that he put a spy in jeopardy from him
and where did you hear that
the Washington's okay and so like I have
first up it would depend on the degree
of information I mean we were they in
there playing strip poker and then the
pot was the nuclear launch codes I mean
I don't know we don't know they don't
[ __ ] that's all [ __ ] this I'm
saying like bolts because I have
absolutely no idea in six sources are
going to give you six different versions
of information it's like what I don't
know so baby you saying don't ask the
stupid [ __ ] question you weren't in
there we know at the end of the day
though I don't know you know I don't
look at the president as being the most
powerful person I mean I respect I
respect the office the person who sits
in the chair still has to earn my
respect but that person is only as
effective as the people that are around
him the team that he put her together
and there's no way that he could have
insight into everything the military is
doing and the intelligence organization
and work on the economic stuff so it is
anything like the military when you go
and you briefed your boss on something
that's getting like you know you look at
his calendar and he's got to do a brief
to the Admiral on this day well in the
days leading up to that you briefed them
up on the talking points that he's going
to get yeah he doesn't really operate on
a day to day level with an innate
knowledge of what's going down but the
boots on the ground level so I mean I
and I don't know much about the
president of the Office of the President
I would assume it's the same way though
because the bureaucratic organization is
multiple Society there's a structure
I think she's gonna leak something you
know I don't think just leak it no one
knows when you're right
that's also his little girl just said
that what did you say what did you say I
don't think in word yeah his national
security adviser help if you know you
Pig yeah yeah no oh sorry let me change
the commands and they tracked everything
he does unless he unless but he is
briefed so unless he was briefed so if
he has a short attention span which they
say he does so he just wants to bullet
points problem is sometimes when you get
the bullet points and you kind of spill
the beans
they're like bro there was so much
behind the fact that we know that that
you can't and all of a sudden the
Russians go well how do they know that
there's a threat to Airlines with
laptops and all that [ __ ] and they can
put them in a cook notes would be
important as well and I'm assuming he
gets a briefing every day and it's
probably not best to share that with
somebody who's from a different nation
yeah but again her friends rush knows
though I mean that's what I'm saying you
know if he did spill the beans on that
like that's that's a problem it should
be and it should be addressed but I
think nobody in this room is ever going
to get the brass tacks on whether or not
that actually happened how that's a
problem your kids ask you a lot of
questions in me about what you did
sporadically sometimes around like when
they'll watch movies or my son
surprisingly enough is a fan of
first-person shooter video games yeah
I'm surprised and he wants to know why I
won't play with him because like listen
your tactics suck but you're getting me
so shitty paradigm okay Annie we're
gonna do shock it appears a lot tougher
with Fabrizio yes and I was like as like
Annie I want you on my come will you
come play airsoft makers just tell me
when [ __ ] is house IV because I'm going
to [ __ ] more than likely that exact
response would I get yeah but he like my
son like likes to run in the middle of
room and do circles and jump up and down
and and I'm like you know peeking around
the corner and you shoots me every time
so I refused to play instructure doesn't
reward good tactic so that sources dog
[ __ ] will you be opposed if they want to
fall in your footsteps
it would be probably one of my biggest
fears just as I'm sure it was the
biggest fear of my parents my mom came
from army brat sided house both her mom
and dad serve in the army
my dad was a machine gunner on the first
squadron of patrol boats in the
nom had no desire I'm assuming for me to
fall in the career path that I did and I
come home one day when I'm 17 and they
knew I wanted to be a seal like from 11
years old yeah I come home one day I was
like hey uh yeah I just went to the Navy
recruiters office and can you guys sign
here because I'm a minor
but I'm listing the Navion so I'm gonna
need some signatures then they signed it
so and it allowed me to become the
person that I wanted to be and I have no
right to prohibit my kids from doing the
same thing well but you're doing I
wouldn't say you know the obviously the
Navy SEAL stuff is insane as far as how
tough it is and just that whole journeys
insane not that big of a deal do over
that office relax on your little date is
I am ready yeah it is but go back on
don't work that hard know what's going
on here so you're Navy SEAL then you
jump in you're in the squirrel suit one
son's like I won't be named seal the
youngin was like yeah won't be the
squirrel guy you're like what you're
just like what the [ __ ] but you cause
this kinda like it's like Tiger watching
a frickin psycho yeah you know the
reality is is that I don't think neither
my kids or my wife give two shits about
what I do they're into their little [ __ ]
they're into their Eliza your wife says
nothing when I can't be able I'm headed
to auntie Gwen with a jump off this
[ __ ] mushy acid the life insurance
policies fade out this your wife and
I've met her your wife cuz they came to
my show in San Diego your wife you've
been married how long uh 16 years she
was with you through the whole [ __ ]
thing where you'd be gone for 300 days
never knowing if there was a knock at
the door yeah she's got to be a piece of
work she's got to be a solid or dead
behind us or dead behind you the awesome
or some both gentle have you guys I mean
that's amazing I mean there's a chance
she might listen to this so I'm not
gonna answer yeah yeah no I mean it's a
sheet of died piece too by the way I
mean she'd been looking when she's been
she's been through a ton and I think she
just inherently trusts me to make good
decisions I mean I think I'd be alive
today because I have a history of making
the best decision that I can and being
responsible so I mean she's into her own
stuff I mean I just I kind of do my
stuff in the morning you know I wake up
every morning I make the kids lunch they
go off to school she heads off and does
her worst thing I had it to the drop
zone get as many jumps in as I can we
figure out who's going to pick up the
kids and
Wow minutes just what will you so that
full your full time jumpers at the yes
dad tire dad / jumper yeah yeah jumper
like a tomorrow I'll go jump and I'll
probably knock out somewhere between 8
to 10 jumps and one of those new
wingsuits why are you doing that
it's because it's all about feel you
know you're driving a car you got a
speedometer a tachometer you got Lane
lines and it's all you got all that
information
I know it all feel I take tennis lessons
okay I work on my tennis congratulation
out now you're jumping the [ __ ] out clay
must be any I'm saying dude I'm like
right hey bro I boxed too but you're
holding really I'm like I'm looking at
this what I asked you I asked you I
tried to tell I listen to the man I
might in Sparta day with a Fayette full
face care here's the thing and we're not
going to art now here's the thing and we
and we bump up now here's the thing Andy
I understand it you're doing a lots of
jumping and you're doing that is the
goal to get a world record which I think
you already have done with that I
wouldn't do that jump again if you pay
me but you had that world record I never
actually filed for the world record I I
broke the record and that whole thing
was just again around the fundraising
stuff that's the one we saw where you're
on top of things
on top of this maybe that of an airplane
become I think of all those do you have
that video somewhere I'm not that
excited interesting video of your mother
oh yeah idea so what now when you jump
in everyday is it obviously to get a
feel for the soup but is it some big
like everybody like it's like training
but are you doing it because you have a
big jump coming up or it's just it's for
longevity for survival this suits like I
said it's also new skydiving is less
consequence-free so you can do a lot of
stuff you can do some acrobatic stuff
you can you can get bent out of shape in
your suit and learn how to recover from
it you can get steep you can fly flat
and you don't want to mess with any of
those things in a BASE jumping
environment because you're much closer
to the ground so and again there's no
there's no
gauges it's all it's all tactile it's
all what you can see and how you feel
like you feel the suit inflated because
of the speed if it feels ridges it feels
a little bit looser like it gives you
feedback of what
you can do with the suit so I mean the
same I would assume like when you were
doing fighting if you take a month off
you get back in you like got it I mean
like I'm doing the right things but it
just timings off yeah it doesn't feel
right and usually I do my BASE jumping
trips in either July or August so I want
to be as current in my suits as possible
before I get over make sense because
you're addicted to jumping let's be
honest unless I've had some of the best
experiences of my life jumping and I
think I've had probably the most
terrifying experience of my life jumping
so I've had to pull her off you don't
plan to stop anytime soon as the point
I'm making how old are you and email 39
39 so you're not oh can is there a lot
of 50 year olds jump in six year old six
year old seven year olds hold up seven
year olds in a squirrel suit look up
about how old it's grossly I don't know
squirrels to them all right find me okay
look how look how old is the last time
you did at an amusing is 98 am L broke
squirrel suit at 7:00 if you like a bad
idea
now if we you and I do a tandem jump
explain what that means and could it
look any gayer and yeah I can make it we
do that okay you you will have the
choice I will be clothed
okay okay I mean a tandem jump is easy
it's actually the best exposure to
people jumping and you know when I said
a second ago the worst experience of my
jumping career probably one of the
scariest ones of my life was on a tandem
why
so what maybe we should do the tandem
before I tell somebody I need to hear
some are different but I'll give you an
example of what a tandem is easy I mean
it takes like 10 minutes to fill out the
waiver
I took cam for a tandem it was awesome
he came down pit yeah he's phenomenal
that dude gets me up early in the
morning he works Harvard at him yeah he
just do just grinds it out right so for
sure quick regular job focus on all the
[ __ ] you're doing what's he do for a
regular job works for the water Water
Authority I don't know to like whatever
he should just keep doing what he's
doing because he's making the world a
better place but you know you shows up
he fills out a waiver sometimes the
waiver takes longer than the actual jump
itself throw you in a harness you're in
a harness I'm in a parachute I briefed
you on what's going to happen but really
all I need you to do is smile and relax
because if you can smile you're probably
relaxed the wind does it for you you
know it's a gas and you can feel it
pushing against you the resistance as
soon as you jump out of the plane I have
all the responsibility and you just get
it it's a good exposure to skydiving and
most people do their first jump
attached to an attached to another
person so for you and I you know
definitely will go clothing-optional
yeah you I'll be closed inter wait
limited I'm a Felco there is you and I
both big does sidle you would have to go
to the mall or a tandem a sir because
there's this maximum suspended weight
you wouldn't want the harness to fail
even though I'd be willing to give it a
go for you because I like you're good
actually today I'm bad day for me in a
formality sweet-talk me I will go facing
instead of facing are there any Navy
SEALs as big as he is hell yeah
really in dudes who are like 280 Jesus
Christ Jesus seriously so you ready for
a good tan story this is the worst
probably experience in my life and you
do it with them comes in so I'll give
you the choice I'll take you for a
tandem first or I'll tell you this not
long ago let's do the story gonna be
more more scary so if I look back in my
career I actually am probably more proud
of some of the jump stuff that we did
because we figured out a complex
solution to a difficult problem you tell
my steel team stuff so team stuff we did
a lot of testing and evaluation and
there's places in the world that are
really hard to get to and a lot of the
times we use assets that are really loud
and guess what people hear those assets
they know what that generally means if
they're on their a game and they bail so
maybe it'd be a good idea to be able to
get people to remote areas so we went
all over the US up into Colorado we did
jumps into the lead Vil Airport like in
an elevation about 10,000 feet and it's
difficult we did tree stuff we did
mountainous exits we did nighttime stuff
we jumped equipment we jump bundles we
played around with all sorts of
different canopies just to figure out
these complex solutions of getting
people places that are hard to go yeah
and I have always liked jumping so I was
kind of specialized in doing the tandems
for those operations surprisingly enough
I don't speak English at like a probably
a high school level you get me into a
foreign country I can't speak the
language nor can most guys so we have to
bring with us interpreters oh yeah who
don't know how to jump out of airplanes
yeah well very were it's so a good thing
because you now you took out our
airplane with a mouthpiece that
basically a google translator I'll get
better
so so there we were in a galaxy far far
away back in like 2004 and the complex
complex problem presented itself and we
needed to take somebody who spoke the
the native tongue and at the time I
needed to go pack to parachute so I
actually didn't see the passenger until
we got on to the c-130 aircraft at night
now mind you this was going to be we
were on oxygen for this jump so we were
at least 15,000 feet above ground level
I think the drop zone was at five to
seven thousand feet so we were in the
mid-20s how cold is it hit up there over
getting the excess out of story so it's
nighttime the brief goes down I go and I
pack the parachute another one of the
tandem masters puts the interpreter into
a tandem harness now the civilian tandem
harness that I'll put you in doesn't
have some of the attachment points
because my rucksack with all of my stuff
then went on the front of him I had my
weapon on me and he had two oxygen
bottles on him with one hose going to me
one hose going to him it was a complete
[ __ ] [ __ ] show I mean it's really if you
were to look up [ __ ] show there might be
an extra a complete [ __ ] show just a
scared little chance later like this all
right here do that all right fool dude
so it's nighttime right the ambient paid
an hour I don't know
do you quit two days after the test I
think you guys didn't make it specific
so we go out there and the ambient
lighting on a c-130 to preserve your
division before we flip down our goggles
is red lights because it helps preserve
your night vision we get onto the
airplane I meet this dude he is wearing
man jammies which is basically very thin
it looks like a dress for a dude and
sandals now I am wearing every piece of
cold-weather clothing that I owned kids
it was the wintertime and I looked at
him and I was like good for you sir I
appreciate your effort yeah come to find
out he had never been in an airplane so
not only was he about to do his first
flight he's about to do his first jump
that night at an altitude in the mid-20s
in a galaxy far far away I'm saying this
is for men and some sandals so now me I
have every layer of cold-weather gear on
possible gloves and so the flight takes
off there's a little bit of a flight
time I'm sorry to interrupt you did
anybody anybody say bro you need a
jacket you need some pants shooters
choice you know you bring to the table
what you want to play with
gotcha okay all right yeah he might had
some more meson underneath I was just I
was like all right cool its aggressive
but I received back to him I did that
stupid record jump with a long-sleeved
t-shirt on I'm not the smartest person
either right it was negative 50 that
exit altitude for that jump so it's I'd
like to say I'm a sharp tool in the shed
I'm not a rake you know I mean I'm more
along the lines of like an axe or a
shears yeah like that but I don't always
make the best decisions either so the
plane takes off and about 30 minutes you
know there's a lot of time in flight so
I go to sleep airplanes put me to sleep
he didn't go to sleep he for whatever
reason I can't figure out why I was a
little bit more emotionally evolved
I wonder yeah so he starts throwing up
about 10 minutes before we have to jock
up because it's a whole it's very
structured military freefall is very
structured it's based on 20 minute
warnings 10 minute warnings and it's 6
minutes before you exit the aircraft for
a military tandem you hook up to your
passenger so he has his little rap hat
on and he was getting sick thrown up
into a bag so we're going to put him on
pure oxygen early so he could you know
it helps you feel better a little bit so
put him on pure oxygen seem to calm down
a little bit at 6 minutes I stand up
we had a great support crew because of
all that [ __ ] show that was attached to
him and then the stuff is attached to me
I basically just stood there and
everybody else hooked me up and there
was another jump master just to make
sure that everything was going to go
okay because the tandem stuff can be
complex with all those extra components
and then the ramp comes down so to add a
layer to this story we were not a very
far distance from another sovereign
nation i'ma leave it at that so we get
ready to jump and the way the ramp comes
down and there was this weird suspended
dust in the air it looked like pea soup
through my night-vision goggles I don't
know what it looked like
through the turps eyes because he didn't
have a pair of night-vision goggles you
know well he goes no I mean he had his
eyes the ability to see - not at the
plane has been warm up - a mouse right
and now yes the temperature goes down as
the ramp comes down yeah and so we're
looking out and there's two lines of
people getting ready to jump and the way
it works is one line goes out followed
by the other one it's better than having
one really long line because as each
person goes the gap in between kind of
it increases and I'm going to c-130
every second you are delayed from
another jumper is 100 yards because
they're going so offensive so if you're
once yeah so we had let's say we had 10
jumpers let's say there was one second
separation between them that's a
kilometer between the first jumper in
the last jumper you so shorten that you
can go side-by-side there's a variety of
ways but the goal is to get out as fast
as possible 3 as closest to each others
you can be because we navigate together
under canopy talking on our radios in my
oxygen mask is my radio I have the
ability on my chest I have a navigation
board with a compass and altimeter and a
GPS in but only [ __ ] gear oh this was
a game on like we were going to fully
navigate under canopy we probably had
been under canopy for maybe 20 30
minutes just what is an under canopy
mean that parachutes open over your head
we had high glide parachutes so we were
traveling a substantial distance totally
blacked out no markings either overt or
covert we had no IR stuff because we
were aware that other people had the
ability to have see that IR signature
stuff what is IR infrared so there's
chemical officious yeah there's chem
lights you can crack that glow not to
the naked eye that through night-vision
goggles it looks like a beacon or we
have strobe covers that our IR strobe
covers you flip it on and you can see
the flash but anybody who has the IR
ability to see that or even old like
Sony cameras have a night vision setting
you can look up there you can see that
stuff as well so we're fully blacked out
I have my own little navigation kit and
the plan was is that I was the last guy
in the first row because I have to
basically waddle and this dude by the
way two inches taller than me which is
unheard of for a person that I do clean
that gallabat is kind of bad nutrition
are almost unheard of from a dude from
that galaxy so the goal is so this first
row starts going I'm going to be the
last jumper to go but hopefully I have
waddled to the edge by the time the rest
of these people go so right as the last
guy goes I go immediately as well and
because you're jumping with another
human being who has a vote unfortunately
when you do a tandem if you look at a
video of somebody doing a freefall and
attain them there's a drogue parachute
that's suspended behind them it slows
down two bodies to the speed of one
because there's only you have the double
weight but only one surface area cutting
the wind so that drogue parachute has to
be out for your main parachute to come
off your back coming out right away a
little smaller it's a little small and
it's on you down so in the military
setting these guys are the guys I was
with we're jumping out and they were
pulling their parachute 4 seconds later
because we wanted to fly under canopy
not fall down ok so the faster you can
get your parachute off your back the
better well I need to have that drogue
parachute out before I can pull my main
parachute so I had a guy standing on the
ramp of the aircraft who was holding on
to that drogue parachute which probably
saved my life because at about the point
in this story this is where it
transitions to one of the worst
experiences of my life
so the first jumper goes into the
pea-soup
by these guys in front of you he Hall
again in front him all the gear this way
it looks like I'm jumping over this
visual rhinoceros in front of me yeah I
mean and he's taller than me and he's
just kind of holding onto the rock and
he sees people start to jump and at that
point decided that he was no longer
interested in the skydiving evolution
not your choices far by the minute so he
puts his feet out in front of us and
starts clawing like a cat that's wet to
try to get a hold of the side of the
aircraft so my only choice is to bear
hug him at this point and start hip
checking him to get towards the ramp oh
you going so now mind you though that my
my row is already gone now the other row
they're gone too and I'm on the airplane
by myself seven seconds eight seven nine
seconds I finally get up to the edge of
the aircraft holding onto this dude and
we basically go out feet first
standing up his feet hit the wind first
and we immediately start spinning like a
top which thankfully that my buddy who
ended up jumping out after us he also
got completely hosed in this evolution
he held on to my drogue until it came to
extension and I'd have enough experience
that I felt it tug on the gear I just
felt the sensation that the drug was out
and I immediately pulled our parachute
even though we were spinning like a
complete top oh my so the parachute
comes out and the lines are just twisted
three-quarters of the way up now mind
you I can see all this my man is just
levitating in space I think though he
was using tshis now the worst
his life he's just now in it he is now
levitating right he's just now in the
pitch black he could probably hear the
c-130 flying away
freezing whatever so the parachutes
opening and as we went out because his
feet went out first my body kind of sunk
down underneath him the drogue pulled
and then pulled us to a belly to the
earth orientation which shifted him the
direction it should have been but it
grabbed that board that had all of my
navigational tools and pinned it in
between us you can see we will get to
that it's good
so the parachute opens I get all the
twists out and now in the meantime while
all this is happening so I'm in the
airplane probably by myself for I'll say
between 10 to 15 seconds so we're
talking at least a kilometer to a
kilometer and a half from the last
jumper that got out before me here so
far away but now I can hear them talking
because there's a series of procedures
you know you make sure that everybody's
there the lead jumper starts navigating
they're waiting for me to check in and I
would like to think that I'm pretty good
at keeping my [ __ ] together
and I always prided myself on sounding
calm on the radio
I don't know how calm I was sounding in
these particular moments because they're
waiting for me to check in and I'm
probably like I got some [ __ ] going on
but like my I was in an elevated state
at this point alright oh yeah I wasn't
the pot wasn't boiling but there was
some [ __ ] bubbles on the bottom of
the pan yeah so I get the canopy open
and I can't see anybody I can hear him
checking it on the radio I can hear him
calling the Bering that they're going to
be flying so they were trying to give me
references to help me out so now the
canopy is open I'm looking down at a
mountain range and somewhere in this
mountain range is a border to a country
and I don't know if I'm flying towards
it or away from it all it looks like is
a mountain range and so you know pre GPS
I used to do it was a point man so I
walk up front I would do compass
navigation but a lot of the times you
just pick a star and if you can find the
North Star right you can or you tell it
yourself and you can navigate well
surprisingly enough and you look at the
stars through night-vision goggles
they're all pretty goddamn bright
so I'm looking for the North Star and
I'm just like haha I like the north yeah
so there are all just beacons and of
course there's millions of them so like
that's out so I just picked it too right
and I and I and I'm trying to get in
between me and the tandem passenger and
at this point I can feel him in front
he's kind of convulsing a little bit
crying I don't know what was going on
and then it seemed like we were flying
through like basically like a cloud so I
started getting moisture all over me and
I'm reaching and I'm reaching in and I
finally get the compass board out that
has the compass which is largely
irrelevant at this point the altimeter
which gives me that visual reference and
then my GPS was which I really wanted
because I had all of the points locked
into place and I could just hit you know
go to and navigate to one thankfully and
for my benefited factory reset so it was
showing me as being directly over the
top of Hong Kong so that was really
helpful in that situation so Holly Fogg
and how much time has gone by so far
couple minutes and so you know and again
I just keep getting wetter and wetter
and I'm trying to manipulate the GPS my
gloves are now completely soaked and at
this point our canopy goes into a
radical dive and I look to see what it
is and the tandem passenger has climbed
up and he's grabbed one of the control
causes and he's hand over handing up the
control toggle initiating this crazy
spin down store he's just panicking he's
panicking well he can't see anything to
me it's a daylight to him it's just a
nightmare that he's living you must
silence it almost been better choke him
the sleepless jump no we're getting to
that so my only my only emergency
procedure that I could think of to
remedy the problem was to elbow him at
the back of his head as hard as I could
I was trying to separate his spine
actually if I'm being honest I was
trying to knock his head off of his
spinal column because you were both
gonna die we were both going to die so
he goes limp eventually and I just go
back to work so poor God just try to
help
thank you ah you're gonna be super way
to understand that wants to spin start
coming and they start increasing it's
like the centrifugal force and bad
things can happen they can accelerate on
themselves and can get uncontrollable so
I was just literally trying to solve the
problem yeah so now I'm totally wet I'm
trying to get my GPS on I can't and so I
have already taken my oxygen mask off I
hate those things and we had been at
altitude enough that I felt fine I left
the oxygen mask on him so I can't push
the buttons on my GPS so I needed to
take my glove
off and the only option I had to do was
to bite it off and as I brought up my
glove to my mouth to bite it off I
realized that it wasn't moisture from
the air it was vomit from the passenger
in front of me that I was covered in
because he was filling up his oxygen
mask with vomit to the anti suffocation
valve which was then spitting all over
me ah so I had to bite off every finger
of my glove through his vomit ah it
feels great I'm sure it's great so I
spit it into the app just like just spit
it off keep working with my GPS the
whole time I'm trying to check in on the
radio try to find the rest of the guys
trying to pick a point to land at at
some point it's like I don't know where
I am I now have to pick a landing zone
and I'm on my own be like what dead
weight with no idea what maybe what he
wakes up again it gets better again so
as I'm messing with the GPS again and
I'm looking over my shoulder we started
die than the other direction because he
repeated his emergency move of trying to
climb he never hopped up like a zombie
he came back and [ __ ] translating
zombies that he came uh vomit vomit
everywhere
yeah I'm covered right so it me idea
what he was eating very bit later yes
because I saw his oxygen mask there was
carrots in there there was some eggs in
there it was offset I try to figure out
what right he was they stuff the baby in
American food because it is with us on
the bed
carrots and eggs are great yeah he
should chew better though but I digress
so to eat an hour in the left hand turn
and I just went back to my original
procedure and just start beating the
crap out of this dude so he'll just
leave it a little blah he how did you do
it
not the time to talk about right baby
inside of your head so he goes he's he's
out again he relaxes it's like hey buddy
take it easy
so he's and so in the position he's in
relaxing imagine being suspended from a
harness and he's just got all arms and
legs went down too and his toes are like
the lowest point so I eventually
realized we're not going to make where
we're supposed to be I'm going to be by
myself so let's find a suitable place to
land and I look and I find basically a
dry riverbed but you can see there's
boulders and rocks and all sorts of on
your GPS no oh I have no idea isn't
through my time just visually looking
down
frickin mountain range that the
Himalayas you know the mean of the
Everest is in the Himalayan range is the
southern end of it and you're like I ten
inviting area it is that's super in five
and it's like I picked out an area where
looks like a dry riverbed and you know
we land a canopy you want to land it
into the wind because it slows your
forward speed and it makes landing much
easier by this point I was very upset
not only at what the situation but the
individual who was attached to me so I
went the opposite route I intentionally
set up to go downwind so we would have
more speed to punish him more yes to
punish him and so I brought in cold and
I brought it in and get ready to land I
mind you he's sitting there I think he
was awake at this point because he's
moving around but his toes are just
dangling and now I can see the ground
coming he cannot so about a hundred feet
off the ground I just let go the
steering toggles and I went into the
pose that I go with when I do like
calendar shoots you know on a bearskin
rug where you had like your hands sure a
chin and your feet and legs were off you
know that that position that is hot so
he contacted the ground with his toes
and I surfed him out probably doing that
pushing on the back of his head for
probably a hundred to see you used
typically got surfboards I didn't touch
the ground until we came to a complete
stop this is great yeah so three surf it
in he deserved it because you know he
was there I'm sure if it in I unhooked
from the tandem grab my weapon went to a
high ground like just stay here mind you
the most heavily landmine country on the
face of planet she's go to some high
ground get the radio get in contact with
an aircraft they push an aircraft over
we're nowhere near where we're supposed
to be so then I go back and I now I'll
go check and make sure my guys okay
right because his safety is my main
priority of this entire sign and we go
back and enough so I see his altimeter
is completely shattered from you know
MOA you wrote him you wrote him for a
hundred feet you wrote him like a
behavior a mincer or yeah you know was
your wakeful I wish it was 150 he was a
clean suit but at least at least the
riverbed didn't have any rocks and it's
a really it wasn't cold it's a small
ones from al to do were about the size
of Volkswagens so it's amazing how
things get bigger is you okay can I get
a can I get a reading on the temperature
on the ground is okay okay all right
forties and fifties so we pack up all of
our stuff and in doing so I got a look
at his oxygen mask which was cracked
because it is I don't know he had to hit
it on something but in there
he basically had had him wearing it the
whole time I didn't because I didn't
realize he was throwing up so he
basically was skip breathing on his own
vomit throwing up on me and it was just
like eggs Stu put all that in a bag
picked it up and we just walked the rest
of the night until we could land I was
able to walk yeah until we were
everything all right by the way he's
fine that's a tough [ __ ] good if
I if I told that story as him the story
would go I they told me I could make a
lot of money and just doing translation
I got to find a plan never flown on a
plane before was really cool it was
going to be blood supply's I showed up
and I had a couple layers on and then
next I know they they strapped me to
this dude who was really mean to me and
he had all this gear on he was he didn't
speak any English
but he's kind of a thick guy and I got
strapped to him and then I had to put a
bunch of stuff on my belly and I was
like what jumping out huh
and he's got someone on a plane I never
been in a plane so I started throw
because I was terrified and then I kept
throwing up and then I lost
consciousness and I was breathing my own
vomit and then he was hitting me in the
[ __ ] head yeah barely harder sort of
because if any don't do it yeah hit it
yeah understand I'm just saying for him
last night
it wasn't my choice you know it's a
rough time for me though you know
something we were jumping out of a plane
- that is hilarious man that within your
rizal everyone's like yeah says the
worst jumping experience of my life
I said you guys you guys hooked it yeah
so we linked up with an army hoping you
don't step on a landmine well I did tell
him to walk 50 feet in front of me you
used to big 1% his uh as God as what I
what a [ __ ] night what a night so he
claimed insanity two days later and quit
never saw me I was gonna say damn right
II quit we got back to the base linked
up with the guys he did a full forward
phase high-lift track into a cot slept
for like 36 hours and then quit when he
woke up you're [ __ ] right that's
extra way all my clothes like it was I
didn't realize I mean a lot of the
pieces of the story like the vomit thing
was like oh that's why my clothes
absolutely stink like it yeah it was a
mess terrifying one of the worst
experiences in my life so I've had some
of the best jumping yeah and then that
happens yeah yeah but that's it I really
think do everyone do the animal 30 times
you know spray shop - I would
walking yeah cuz it'll be in San Diego I
was riveted dad that was oh god what a
[ __ ] it sounds so surreal that kind
of story and also like I was thinking
about how much how detail-oriented you
have to be to be like a seal like or
just all the shit's all in the details
yeah and also technology savvy nowadays
well and the risk is to rely on the tech
that's it I mean what if you're I mean
because it is it's uncanny how tackle
not respond for you wouldn't wanted to
just like that GPS faculty said it yep I
have never seen that happening yeah but
I had a compass but I just I wasn't
prepared to use it and I'm like God I
was Leslie navigate I mean I had never
tried to celestial navigate on nods
which is impossible I mean it's all
bright and you know so people coming to
military now they rely on GPS yeah I
still and I mean I teach my kids this is
how you navigate on a topographical map
using landlines and features you don't
need a compass you know this is what how
you can tell direction like this is what
this mountain looks like on a map and
you have to maintain those baseline
skill otherwise your actual the breadth
and depth of what you're able to do is
super thin and you're relying on you
know double-a batteries which is not a
good idea you know let's say there's
like somebody you can take with you
I'll get pissed so bad yeah I have to ID
that story I had to pee we started it
I'm good now lousy I gotta hear this yes
guy now let's go Pete and we'll come
back perfect let's do it
let's get on anyway we're back from our
pee break ladies and gentlemen with any
stumps oh my god that's my top stories I
was legit and addressed yet and worst
experience ever
wisely we have that guy on the ceiling -
perfect I'll be here yeah I mean it's
before you go man he's back and he's
pissed and he has some use his side of
the story you gotta swear huge road rash
on his face still can you imagine his
side of the story holy cow I'm saying
that would be actually be pretty
interesting to sit down and be like so
sir from your eyes what was it I got
just pure chaos
it was dark I'm sewing up I was inhaling
through six I know I any opal doing that
mathematics guy kept hitting me in the
head every time I come to and knocking
me out so then I try to get out of there
cuz I was loosening I tried to climb
this rope that ice
in front of me and then I really got a
beating I asked him why he did that
actually on the ground and he said that
he was afraid that the harness was going
to fail so he literally was trying to
climb up in a in a sense of
self-preservation
oh let's see a point well you know we
all we don't know how we're going to
react until we're there you were a guy
who had 3500 plus jumps not dead I
probably had 500 jumps at that point
okay well either way my friend I thought
it was I'm hit on for size he had he
never been in a [ __ ] play yeah so
he's allowed to have a little bit of a
moment I thought why not a little bit is
there seeing a little bit of moment
[ __ ] the bed and almost killing you
and not is not in his skill set he's
just a simple interpreter maybe well
outside of his comfort zone and I was at
the absolute limit of what I was I was
at my limit of being able to control
myself emotionally and physically there
was so much stuff you tell me I know
like how for us civilians like if we're
in a really dangerous situation how do I
teach you guys to stay calm like if it's
really a bad situation yeah okay well so
I would say you know I talked so I do
about half of your jumping off of stuff
and out airplanes buy the other half a
year I do public speaking and a lot of
it is about leadership stuff and we know
one of the key points when it comes to
being a leader is being able to control
your emotions because they're infectious
if you've ever worked for a team and
you're working for somebody who you have
a lot of respect for and you see them
starting to lose the bubble you can sit
back and watch what it does to everybody
else it's the rising tide theory right
so when your boss starts losing it
you're like whoa what's going on like
this guy's he is dialed in he's got
experience he's losing his mind maybe
I'm not seeing something that I should
so I'm going to lose my mind a little
bit so emotions are really infectious
and being able to control your emotions
is probably one of the most powerful
characteristics of a leader especially
if you're an environment where things
are going terribly wrong and you hear
your boss come over the radio and he's
in the same firefight as you are or
trying to work out a complex problem in
the same environment that you are but he
sounds like he's having mai tais on the
beach it just immediately ranch you back
down a few
but it has to be taught and it starts
with understanding that emotions don't
impact outcome in any positive aspect
but they have a huge negative downside I
mean it really doesn't matter how much
you want something to happen or how
scared you are or how excited you are
how enthusiastic that does not infect
outcome unless you let it affect your
judgment so there's nothing it positive
that it can do and even like say you hit
target after target after target after
target and you develop the sense of
security a false sense of security
everything's been going your way even
that emotion can be very dangerous on
the negative side
it's superstitious right weren't you
talking about that like it's not
superstitious it just it's an emotion
that's allowing you to think that things
are always going to go in your way and
it doesn't so we start getting
frustrated and it impacts your ability
to make decisions your performance goes
down when you start getting too excited
and it impacts your ability to make
decisions or you make a decision based
off that false sense of security bad
things can really happen so it's it has
a huge consequence and it's just
something that is reinforced from day
one like you have to maintain control of
your emotions and if you're going to be
in a leadership position and we expect
all seals from day one both officer and
enlisted to exude leadership and I mean
the classic line is in the absence of
leadership you need to step up and take
charge
you have to don't wait for somebody else
to do it you step up yourself and in
training the training that we do is
extremely difficult and we take it to
failure all the time like we'll create a
problem that is not fixable and we'll
let people start to freak out and you
stop the training evolution you're like
listen you see how things are going bad
here this is why it's going bad and you
highlight those failures so they can
learn from them in a training
environment as opposed to never
addressing them and then you end up in a
real world situation and it's
catastrophic because most of us are
afforded that luxury right so what I
noticed is that most people will go
through life say things like this they
go um you know if it's meant to be you
know it's going to happen or for example
a lot of times they like people are very
superstitious about things like they're
like first most people think it can't
happen to me we all do that right so
most people think I've got it I've got a
little angel watching over me in
computer my like bad things I'm just
talking about yet you see that a lot of
people are sort of irrationally out
to Mystic about certain things like just
I was reading this thing about I was
going to do is I'm driving I was texting
and you know this texting has become and
not just that social media in your car
people are dying at an alarming [ __ ] so
they took over drunk driving everything
I mean it's crazy I drop that knowledge
yeah it came driving it yeah yeah it's a
worse problem than drinking driving
reading drive anything and they're
trying to come up with this this
computer program that allows the police
to see if you were swiping or text I saw
the hose to voice the text so that our
and you know it's the American Civil
Liberties like it's a little bit of an
overreach but I can understand it man
because if it if they're going to prove
that it's as bad as drinking and driving
then you've got to approve of that and
it'll in the next time I'm texting and I
find and I know that I could they can
find that out and I'll be liable for
murder I'm not going to text so in a way
I'm kind of for that law but the point
I'm making is that would you guys I
guess you become such a [ __ ] realist
with everything even though you've had
say 100 missions that went your way we
all go you know you get comfortable and
you human beings will get comfortable
and more you know kind of relaxed and
routine which can be a good thing but it
comes to be a bad thing and then people
die and they learn not to do that I mean
why you go so B's like I said we spent
all this time planning and briefing
before we actually go out and we have
really good intelligence and you learn
not to put too much weight in any of
that that's all the prep work so you
have all the contingencies planned out
like the what-ifs because those are
really what makes the bread and butter
if this happens what are we going to do
and having those things figured out
before they happen but I have planned
hundreds of combat operations and take a
guess as to how many of them went down
as planned zero zero zero zero so you
learn that the plan is so you put in the
requisite amount of thought the
intelligence can give you a picture but
you have to accept the world as it
presents itself to you you can't force
your plan on the world but I'm sure even
with the training and you guys getting
put in these high-pressure situations
and in those situations some guys passed
that test but when it comes down to the
real and there's real bullets flying I'm
sure even at that level there's some
guys who don't respond like you thought
they would every team has the lowest
performing 10% even the teams that win
the Superbowl even the highest most
elite levels inside of the middle
sorry team human being has you know the
lowest 10% I think you go that vegan
well what does that mean 10 percent
meaning pairs even in a super high
performing team right there's always the
lowest performance there's someone's
there's literally the best and there's
always somebody who's going to be the
worst
so yeah the selection process to become
a seal is really good but and I have to
and I constantly reinforce this when I
talk to people and they ask questions
about seals because I call it the
unicorn theory they think that the SEAL
Teams are the seal community exists them
like this beautiful pasture with
rainbows and unicorns running around and
it's like perfection okay
it's a cross-section of society we have
all of the same problems that everybody
else has it terminates any human being
so you can have the same human being
problems and even this really highly
refined and selected team that has gone
through a crazy amount of work to get to
where they are no process is perfect so
yes sometimes people who respond in ways
that we don't expect they make it
through it's just proof that there's
weeds and every lawn regardless of the
size that's all it is is there is there
like the best because Tim Kennedy posted
my on Instagram I thought was
interesting one time he said I am not
nearly as good an operator as some of
the men I served with because I probably
shot guys I shouldn't have and I didn't
shoot guys I should have and the best
operators were the guys that were able
to make those decisions and be able to
see the difference and kind of know what
is the delineation between the good the
best operators and the guys who are on
the lower 10% can you can you define
that or maybe not maybe it's really hard
to sort of technical proficiency is
definitely I mean it's like basketball
right like if you're going to be a pro
basketball player you need to have some
level of type fundamental vision some
people I think have a little bit maybe
more intuition or a faster processing
speed and they can uptake information a
little bit faster which therefore lets
them make decisions a little like a
quarterback like a good quarterback
versus I go yeah you read the whole
backfield an even-tempered personality
so they're not experiencing a large sine
wave of up and down which all human
beings do regardless of what your
occupation is but maybe one that has
lower peaks and valleys would make it
better and I think it's a combination of
all of those things
there are some seals that are not great
shots but did the last person you would
ever want to leave behind because
they're so good at everything else looks
like the team and yeah exactly it's
again like there's the highest
performers in that team and then there's
the lowers the lowest you know it's it
yeah I mean it's probably subjective as
to what makes the best operator but like
the combination of those things yeah
it's good some current events is
fascinating [ __ ] man I love it good he
got gin I'll show you the first one is
actually a police officer in Ohio who
says that'll not the police officer you
didn't want the right photo would be two
guys he found out that there was bags of
powder on the ground and then when he
went back to the station he had some of
the powder on his shirt and he brushed
it off and he actually overdose from
fentanyl he died too then he didn't die
he's hospitalized in kaneohe we guess
since you guys were like I mean I don't
know what word to use those it's in late
so while you guys were late we were
watching the video so I had a little bit
more backstory on this one it was like
on his shirt so he said his buddy said
hey you got some stuff on your shirt he
untucked his shirt said he made contact
with his finger index finger and thumb
and then basically had an overdose on
fentanyl there were some pictures of the
car there was white powder inside of it
what is phenol it's uh opiate or it's a
Pain Suppression medication I think and
I'm sure somebody will crush mint 5 10
times stronger than heroin I think it's
like that 100 EV it's more powerful than
morphine Jesus yeah yeah that's how not
good good hey wait a minute essence by
the way they're awesome days to give us
fentanyl lollipops and when you give in
to people you can take them by their
hands because they'll suck on it like
I'm gonna pass out nobody got the David
I got your tandem jump oh my god we um
you know very just side note one time
and he called me because about details
here so detail-oriented when when
remember when Eddie Bravo and towhead
and Joe Rogan I think you were there
talking about the Kennedy assassination
and the head head I was so upset and we
go that is all good validation shooting
at Andy you know it's alleged it as a
CEO maybe he knows a little something
about the head shots no not about that
just an understanding the internal
energy and how energy is
answer my like oh there he goes 8l Rogan
and hey brah they don't know what the
[ __ ] they're talking about on a
comfortable pace but you know what the
thing is no one in that room does that's
like fun yeah that I know one done yeah
Bryan did all those hobo Rogan I always
read on the road and said he read a lot
about it knows a lot about it you were
like well how about it's just just like
you know what like don't be careful when
you're like you do you want to like do
you have an opinion about that when you
saw his head gaming is that why would
you look I mean I would lean I would
need to look at the angles at the tape
are shot from but I mean just an
understanding of kinetics when you shoot
a bullet it's got a small weight but it
carries a velocity and kinetic energy to
it more often than not the body
especially you're going to hit an
extremity is going to fly away from the
direction that you take a shot sometimes
people do fall forward but it's usually
from the severing of the spinal column
other than that they're going to fall
away that kinetic energy passes through
them so yeah if you get you should be in
the chest I'm gonna fall backwards
obviously unless you lose control of
your lower body like a severing of the
spinal column in that case depending on
where the hinge point is the angle might
Bend you over okay I'm just saying hi
details
you are stealing that I'll be talking
about that Kennedy one is tough right
from the Occam's razor perspective yes
it's easier to look at a single assassin
but like he's like I don't know you got
to look at all the different yeah yeah
there's a lot there that I was just like
God it was I like to use Occam's razor
as a yeah as animals thank you for your
education um so but what so that he's
alright how I just Saudi Don he's
alright but me and Andy saw the video
been talking and he seemed like he was
just sort of telling the story kind of
like hesitant like it wasn't really the
truth and I'm thinking is there
possibility that he might have just done
I tried really vented I don't know if it
in digestion you fingers that I don't
know it either and then when they showed
a picture of the car he said that they
saw people and again I have no idea I'm
just looking at a picture there's only
like a 99.5 percent chance that I'm
right yeah that I could be wrong but
it's so of people without gloves or
turning pills into dust and it's getting
all over the car why didn't they have a
reaction with day OD
that was my and maybe maybe they did
maybe rubbed his eyes or I don't know
but I'm it's less a B he snorted in
order yeah yeah well but I'm good but
they don't look like all these they
don't look like they've paid much
attention in high school that poor guy
he's eyes are going to different
directions the one the right he's all my
crazy eyes on the right he's on a great
I am left and tattoos eyes on on the by
yeah that's just not a good choice I
don't think a lot of good choices going
on with both those guys those are not
the guys who want strapped on your body
when you do a tandem jump like on the
right guy strapped your body before we
get our similarities there similarities
he had that be an issue what is he good
- don't throw don't throw up phenol on
my um I'm just check with my sister
she's a nurse practitioner and like I
mean I was surprised to hear that you
could get a contact tracing so men
Amanda with morphine like it's got to be
inter muscular intravenous and was
oxycontin all that some sale idiots
aren't yeah yeah he might have been
trying to it may have gotten in he may
have I'm not alike I fell over and did a
couple lines on I'm getting the benefit
of the doubt to the cop you guys are
[ __ ] hey you know one euros - all
right this one this girl she stabbed her
boyfriend in a drug alcohol filled rage
Oh hot she's pretty hot and she's
supposed to be like a prodigy from
Oxford University she's going into heart
surgery they're you know inspiring and
urgent spine surgeon and that the judge
that was handling her case says that he
doesn't want to give her jail time
because she has such extraordinary
talents that it'll my ruin her old life
doesn't work that way hey you know what
don't want her saving lives and you know
that they say the sociopaths are drawn
they know she's gonna say blood uh we
have a crystal ball that says she's
actually maybe she'd be the worst
surgeon ever tie sorry
maybe she's killing one but she's not
that good of a surgeon listen guys how
was the knife wound with a guy in for
Cyrus I want her we're operating on my
heart because she just stole my heart
hey your kids over today - she got she
got drunk and did like bunch of drugs
and stabbed her boyfriend drunks
she got drunk she did a drug some kind
of drugs that were not listed and then
she punched the boyfriend in the face
and threw a laptop on him and then
stabbed him with a bread knife in his
leg oh that's not bad by the way
no Thursday night job a couple things
about surgeons uh I've actually had some
intimate relations with a couple
surgeons and when I say that I mean
[ __ ] and yeah a couple a couple
surgeon I swear to God are one oh I
swear to God - and the reason - is
because a friend of mine dated a surgeon
and I got to know all you hung it on the
clip yes his whole clique and let me
tell you something about Sarah Jones
number one of three type A personalities
freaks we gonna see it all freaks
growing and also they say that among the
professions that sociopaths are drawn to
one of weight one is chefs but one is
surgeons because you get to play God
because you are you don't have a boss
you're the guy who is running the
[ __ ] show you're their very effect
you got to be very you know due
diligence is done P crazy picture right
set of tips on and she looks super sweet
- is she doing well she's got gloves on
with the flannels to get the fell first
of all she shadow it looks like skin
Journal of oh she went she's been
leaving water especially the boats
obviously like that waters dirty - that
water looks [ __ ] like that guy throw
up that water is horrifying and she
looks like she's cleaning a boat either
way she's cleaning up a crime scene or
he just Oh Woodward is considered
prodigy among prodigies at the
prestigious institution Wow
she's currently believed to be on
holiday in Barbados your [ __ ] ideas
Tia I'm impressed and by the way it's a
bread knife to the [ __ ] leg this guy
probably cheated on her [ __ ] that guy I
like her
I love to see the guy before ambition
has been to cure heart disease he's got
to see her hearts in the right place
um and that she's at Oxford that means I
think she's a Rhodes Scholar is that
what means I don't know she's a prodigy
that stabs dudes man that exists I'm
impressed with her she's 25 and I'm 50
my heart hurts you're out of your mind a
little easy whatever well we got you
can't wait to tan I'm not matter I'm
here if you guys wanna see the videos
two guys that snuck in and climb to go
to the bridge yes 100
support this but I mean obviously it's
junior varsity because they didn't jump
off the top if you're going to take the
effort take the Express I don't know bro
nobody takes to climb down forever a lot
longer than jumping yes I guess rule
that they would hang off the edges too
and mind you this traffic below this is
boys hmm yeah they're not boys no no I
wish I was a boy I never did with a
resinous boy though these are grown men
I feel like now they're actually a
little kids teenagers yeah of course
this is go well Andy do you laugh at
this it's such a good exit point take
like a nice 10-second delay on that
thing you know it's also one of the
number one ears who says so yeah she
likes a bad way to go
Coronado Bridge right where I live in
San Diego is like the number three we
really jump then you hit that water yeah
well as a surface tension to concrete I
mean beyond I think like a hundred feet
it's the same yeah they said it the way
people have survived like well don't you
dare say he makes a nice cutting edge
without hand no it's not cool I guess
and it broke the surface tension he
found I heard that that's you know I
heard that from don't remember just
somebody said it wants and now I'm
taking people watching movies Kim yeah
it does as a surface tension of concrete
so that's why you [ __ ] get correct
some people have survived but look at
these guys I mean what do you jump off
going Dave bridges survived it's just
like gods like them it's a freezer it's
a freak accident if you survive for sure
and your life's just way worse yeah well
you want to go complete laughs oh my god
yeah I'm like on another full-body test
but imagine though you jump off that
land in the water break your neck and
drown that would be I would assume a bad
way to go having never tried it myself
I'm going to make the assumption it
would be a poor there's a lot of L great
whites so you jump off ya little blood o
bike with the water broke mom open water
blood great white goes with those
toppings on it off and the tide
underneath that bridge is no joke you
get those huge tidal swings in there
yeah you do and it's cold as [ __ ] yet
that's why people do it but I'd like
almost 100 percent you the moral of the
story is if you're going to climb the
Golden Gate Bridge jump parachute and
jump on this that's it how you haven't
go into your bridge note so that would
be illegal would be probably shouldn't
talk about alright what do you guys
think of this it's causing an uproar
because they're saying that the security
equipment is supposed to be a multi
million-dollar equipment and it's like
approved by the Homeland Security and to
ten to two teenagers were there for ten
minutes they didn't get caught on motion
detectors cameras nothing
yeah it doesn't surprise me can't just
figure out figure those images well you
will so let's do damage to my original
odds house enough for egg so that's a
tough one at the end of the day that you
can't stop motivated people regardless
with the measures that you have I mean
there's only willing to risk my life
yeah you're always gonna be able to find
a seam well I agree with that but when
two teenagers who are high on weed can
climb and get in there it's kind of weak
I mean you can take some better
precautionary tendineae so good eye
guards just around like your boards are
naked so it's not or that easy but those
little things are holding on to up to
car batteries you know it's like let's
see electric bridge would make me blame
what I'm not saying it's humane I'm
saying people probably wouldn't touch it
does if it's electric did it hey I
touched eight one time I touched with my
my middle finger I brushed a electric
fence to keep bulls out dude I went on
like that shocked me you look at sorry
wasn't so [ __ ] bad it hurts really it
was like they're like I don't even how
to describe it I mean you ever done that
you're going to executed no but I give
you a touch that with your open hand it
would have cinched your hand around oh
my god they can't get that right yes why
would you test electricity use the back
of your hand oh yeah I know yeah okay
Kelly is electricity
oh my god well there's a vacuum see that
that's my dropping knowledge you [ __ ]
all right so Gisele Bundchen she was on
a CBS Morning Show and she mentioned
that Tom Brady was having multiple
concussions and then he had one like
last year as well and I guess you
shouldn't have said that because he
wasn't on the list of concussion no you
have to be on a list right and you did
have to play a game if you're if you
have a concussion pull the she diagnosed
and now or is a doctor and now they're
looking into whether or not he lied or
if the NFL is covering it up well who
said that he had a concussion is wise
wife on she gem holders concussions or
maybe Tom goes Celts or Abba concussion
did you believe that yeah
yeah oh yeah for me the thing is with
concussions in football you know it's
kinda what you sign up for so when Tom
Brady comes home and goes yeah babe I
your concussion up you play quarterback
you start going for New England Patriots
everyone's trying to rip your head off
so there's gonna be so many more
concussions undiagnosed and not brought
to the light it's just part of the game
and also now if you came out to have a
concussion now you're missing games but
you guys don't women's games know so
it's like part of the deal but also how
did a diagnostic gist and you just say
hey I have a concussion or is there
other symptoms I mean fat kid I have
yeah but I never went I mean you just
have a headache weld headache throwing
up sensitive light you know there's a
number of things there's also I met in
college there's that before the season
started you do this reaction thing kind
of like these puzzles Processing's plot
doesn't speak to us so they do that you
might score 50 let's say all the
concussions they take the testing score
20 like they can't play metal get
interesting yeah I agree with you though
it's kind of like eight but of course
you get the ball every play and people
want to take it from you is Tom Brady
yeah your model that was UGG that throws
football is the best side of it you're
also you're also in the industry like we
watch your mouth he but he's not
complaining though you know Tom Brady's
not there he wants to play that D I use
like of course yeah that's good but also
Giselle shut your mouth make those
golden babies yeah like why would she
went on this interview and you know now
it's a issue for Tom Brady yeah how it
can be shows you for Tom dike which no I
would set out a headache yeah
yeah he just really didn't know the
[ __ ] University never give me easy
get out of that yeah I'm sure he says
that there's someone tired of lovin
you're so right about that you are so
right about that I don't care how hot
she is
her husband is like yeah tonight [ __ ] it
it's always there yeah on something
strange yes she got chin all right this
is a good one this kid over here when he
was born he had like the mother was
having birth issues and he got he was
choking during the birth so he ended up
having cerebral palsy
name is ding ding his name is ding ding
29 years old now his mother didn't give
up on him
doctors his doctors told his doctor so
his mother he's not worth saving he's
gonna have to love intelligence and he
ended up going to Harvard Harvard
worried let's change his name Harvard
Law School ding ding that's when you
leave do not change the song donger ding
dong oh you got accepted to Harvard to
Harvard who must be killing it so
doctors are kind of full of [ __ ] there
yeah least a month's like little a dead
mouse a little not a little bit that's a
lot mother's a lot boy that's it he's
not so cool yeah the name ding ding she
[ __ ] up on yeah when I think of ding
ding I don't know if you ever heard
delete voicemails of Barry Bonds with
his sidepiece oh oh he's paying the side
piece and got leaking you'd call and go
only is that high voice ago I know what
you need tonight you need some ding ding
just saying that I fell good they'd be
like a girl flying into flying into New
York today I'm gonna stop by give you
that ding ding and just hang up I keep
thinking my friend my friends have a
bunch of and ding ding my friend who got
divorced him his wife he called up my
friend and she quite a mess a message
she goes this is what I do it and all I
said he was from Uruguay and he goes I
just want you to know that I'm gonna
come home tonight and I'm gonna [ __ ] the
[ __ ] out of you okay bye romantic
romantic here's yeah that's what I meant
I'd rather have that than ding ding give
you some give me she's being that Louie
girls like oh I am turned on you got a
did he say ding ding if you gotta make a
noise she doesn't know hey girl I'm give
you some head Rama give you I don't
think it makes it better at all and
you're gonna get to you see Jerry Smith
when he got caught that girl blasted DMS
some some girls living his DMZ he's
coming down to play somewhere and he
just responds you know she put like hey
have a good game tonight and he just
replied back trying to get that pipe I'm
calling my wife right now I'm on air and
I'm gonna say I'm gonna go ahead baby
I'm just looking for something tonight I
want to see what she said what's this
this is gonna be really cool or complete
[ __ ] show that is real a flow this is
who she says
she say trying to that pipe jack hey
what's up [ __ ] trying you got pilot
she's good she's doing what my wife
would do ignore the call of course she
rolls her eyes she's already rolling her
eyes at [ __ ] she's bald even a horse
I'm not able to catch an ass [ __ ] God go
do that though got to do that I see she
calls guys hey what's up [ __ ] showing
you that pipe and I see what I wanna do
it's exactly 1 in there this is awesome
opens don't name a kid ding ding and
then although avail doctors in this case
that's so cool on a husband to has been
divorced her go over this whole thing
probably self had a massage is stiff
muscles and would also play educational
games with them what an amazing woman
Wow actually without anyone awesome
there's a woman said itchin that's
pretty much it
free legit cuz I love big cat but oh my
god oh my god I [ __ ] hate for for
Australian cat may be the world's
longest that's a giant cat look at this
cat next to a dog what what dude that
thing the [ __ ] lion that's a what is
that - shell ting the thing is towering
over a Sheltie Sheltie yeah a small dog
that's like no but it's not that small
they're not huge - no they're definitely
not but that's like a giant so I can cat
do you hate cats
they're kind of magical they're not
though the kind of [ __ ] now cats they
say they also you know cat is an animal
they say you could let's say you own a
cat I can take your cat from you're
having back bring it to mind and it's
like yep cuz give it doesn't get it
investigated no it doesn't leave us lady
owners they were big they just speak
just like lions they would kill you they
don't give a [ __ ] about they down
anything I can just put a bowl of food
and water and leave for I don't know six
months come back and it's all good
[ __ ] weird now they both freak me out
but they might have the best analogy
about cats he's like listen you know
dogs you feed them every day you pet
them you play with them and they look at
you and they go you're amazing you must
be God yeah cats you see them try to
play with them you pet them and they
look at you and they go who is this
idiot yeah I must be God yeah yeah it
sure is
that's all right [ __ ] yeah cats are
weird yep even that fancy food and [ __ ]
I'm also allergic to him
they also suck if someone brings this
cat to my live show in Australia I'm
gonna take it at [ __ ] face you should
talk to cam about how they hunt cats in
Australia they said Oh cats they hunt
cats like these cats I can't say no so
all the because they kill the birds I
like in hunting magazines they're
talking about it all time in hunting
magazines all I could be holding up a
cat like a regular house cats well
because they wreak havoc on a lot of the
native birds
something Funky's has so many folks Oh
cats so domestic cats pull up pull this
up domestic cats kill an insane number
of birds in this country every year
Malcolm Oni also hates cats like house
cats for size pence pounds the most of
sophisticated and efficient killers oh
my god they're they kill more birds in
this country it's like I'm big on
Australia Matt let's see let me see what
the Oracle says here there you go it's
no surprise that surveys recently
announced went to two million feral cats
by 2020 and the call isn't part of the
some cool and zakat agenda in Australia
feral cats were trained just by the
first European settlers having kind of a
huge threat to native wildlife they're
blamed for the extinction of several
species unique to the contrary McDaniel
eating your month step good at killing
the locals and they thrive and breed who
kills more cats Australis of Asia oh
that's not my friend nature kills a lot
of cats too right Joonas no I don't know
I thought that person I just know that
can you look up how many cat how many
birds American cats kill it's some crazy
number like crazy it's so fun how many
birds
billions not so fast
Gok chats killed 3.7 billion birds
annually not to say my dad is 3.7
billion I know there's a mini Guttenberg
I didn't either as many as 20 billion
mammals including mice and rabbits are
also killed by cats you see my whole
[ __ ] thing against cats now these
[ __ ]
people love cats you better be careful
well anyone who's just as cats I
don't need my social studies teacher I
will the first time I ever saw a grown
man cry my social studies teacher in
Saudi Arabia was and he had been a
military guy not and came in and he said
he said guys do me a favor and take it
easy on me today Mike I can't like I
guess like can't you're joking
he goes my cat died yet so the hell we
get her to cry I was in eighth grade I
think I don't do that they kiss instead
of the lake for food and I was like
everybody got caught I was like that's a
grown man crying I've never seen that
he's crying over cat which was so far
into me I was like I didn't have cats I
was like and he said he atopic at how to
sit anyway long story short he cried
over Ken broke down right in front of us
I'm gonna one-up your story when I was
in eighth grade I just social studies
teacher came in and he would always you
could tell you had like a fascination
with like you wanted to be a performer
like sing songs and you know anytime
he's bringing this guitar and just play
a little [ __ ] thing and he must been
working hard on it and it was like a
typical [ __ ] Tuesday morning and
everyone sits down he goes I won't play
song for you guys to start today's class
on the place long for you guys as I
wrote myself but worked hard on it he
sits down front of the class and it was
like what breaks great so everyone's an
[ __ ] I was like what the [ __ ] on it
and he gets into this [ __ ] MTV
Unplugged in front of eighth graders
that's embarrassing and it's a love song
well so in the wackos awkward so when
that goes you saw yeah and I swear he
goes he just does share disappointed
faces goes all right tastes guitar was
behind the desk and I thought he's gonna
cry he was like what the [ __ ] is going
on you suck system at bully I know me
you say so I would never say it was
terrible I buddy but launched into a
song and he started singing on the iron
that saves us like he like it was like
this like we're all hang it like not
more than this Pete there's many people
and he just started singing his song
where his muscles were [ __ ] like this
and I'm not kidding his voice was
generic
so what is the song so when I first saw
you my heart fluttered like that and
we're all mr. koala like all right
nobody move everything very still until
this is over this this too shall pass
wear this too shall pass it was I'd
rather be in the water with crocodiles
but this too so fast
I'm dying and also wholesome money
my buddy he's good you just see him the
often here here is the street yes please
mouth and him I might hurt his credit he
stopped by the guitar we all started
laughing right well I'm not a good time
sing right now there is nothing more
embarrassing when somebody starts
[ __ ] singing that itches okay it's
even embarrassing when it you know one
is my girl's birthday and her mom can
st. you to see him and like everyone's
are out you know happy birthday and
she's all happy but oh Jesus the
American Idol radio person about happy
birthday baby and Virgin Records in here
to put in sign me office happy birthday
my gently shine yeah I'm all shitty oh
that's actually really beautiful but if
you sing my wife everybody sings my wife
I'll make everybody sing my wife a birth
like birthday that birthday she gets so
embarrassed she can't help over here she
is so what's up trying to get the pipe
so baby you looking for that pipe you
looking for that pipe tonight am I
looking for one you looking for that
pipe tonight let me give you some pipe
are you talking about your penis don't
call it a penis man cut my [ __ ] you look
nice pipe say yes why why yes your
plumber [ __ ] yeah how lucky are you you
get to have my 50 year old dick yeah
baby thank you that's it where you are
you with the kids I'm walking tall again
oh it's a lot all right can I go Your
Honor I just recorded you on the podcast
enjoy that yeah I gotta go
yeah walking my son home and I'm tell
you that putt you know what are those
weird plumber things again because you
trying to go anal again Brian well it's
just that time doesn't happened you
trying to go that doesn't happen I pay
all the bills and I still don't get that
guy him it all would have gone so
different with my wife your wife would
have freaked out oh she's so used to me
what it's like unloaded on me like I
gotta go
I never mind click yeah my wife is so so
bored with me she's already like she's
seen it all I mean I just she's like
yeah Brian it's a referring to your
penis yeah like so not right after this
[ __ ] Oh call me I'm sorry joke are you
doing the pilot click Andy was laughing
you were giants with awkwardly super
opening killed valley words let me give
everybody a dropping knowledge really
quickly a young man asked me for advice
recently and I started talking to him
and you guys can weigh in on this and I
realized he was asking himself all the
wrong questions he was just asking he
was he was asking him self-defeating
questions and like what if I fail
what if I'm not good enough and I I've
always used this as a technique change
the questions you're asking yourself to
be more helpful change your primary
question most people have a primary
question this is from Tony Robbins but
can't believe I'm doing this but it
helps April most people I know I read it
but I don't I want to give him credit
but it but it works change the questions
you're asking yourself a lot of times
people ask self-defeating questions so
ask yourself a question that's going to
help you like what action will have to
take today to get closer to who I want
to be so that's my Tony Robbins moment
but Andy weigh in on that because you
guys have to ask yourself some pretty
positive questions I imagine when you're
in the theater of war when you're doing
the [ __ ] you do know that your level of
assuming those guys to get be a Navy
SEAL Ian I got a diametrical well well
judgmental judo don't you I would say it
90% of what we do is between the ears
but you know one thing that we don't shy
away from in the teams is failure I mean
if anything we pursue failure because if
you look at you know and I see this all
the time people are afraid of failing
and it's it's ridiculous because
everybody's going to fail all three of
us are going to fail we have failed you
might fail at something today and it
really just depends on what you're going
to do with it so the seal selection
process is looking for people who use it
as motivation as
opposed to the stumbling blocks that's
really all it is so instead of being
afraid to fail pursue those things that
you're scared of failing at and just
dive headlong into those things until
there's something else you're afraid of
failing at which is I mean I agree with
what what you're saying it's just a kind
of different looking at it from a
different angle hmm no there you go
boom confirmed by Andy stump and Tony
Robbins and Tony Robbins my friend
thanks for joining us yeah I'm great
stuff we loved it and lurking we're
going to get on yeah let's talk about
that for a second ah you know they're
still out there doing their thing the
last few months have actually been you
know rough guy got killed in Somalia two
other service members injured on that
target and then guy killed in Yemen in
January yeah you know which speaks
exactly to what that organization is
there to do and it's you know having
seen the notification where there's a
car full of people who go to a house
that's in uniform there's absolutely no
doubt as to what they're doing there
they're not there to have a cup of
coffee and you know I didn't realize how
hard it is or how hard it was on my
family when I was gone I'm actually at
the conclusion now that the easiest job
in the dynamic of being in the military
or in the military family is actually
being the service member because you're
selfishly around the people that you
love doing what it is that you want to
do and everybody else is hoping that
nothing happens and they bear a lot of
the burden of what makes the things that
we do possible and then when that person
gets notification that their loved one
is dead there's a lot of things that has
to happen I mean there's that kids
financial decisions in a moment where
you're totally emotionally compromised
you know I've seen it where the wife
didn't know what to do with the
husband's body cremate bury military
funeral would you want to bury them in
uniform that's like those are super
difficult decisions to make and to have
organizations and people that are there
generally upon notification to help take
that burden off the family it's huge you
know and the steel foundation has a
breadth and depth of programs everything
from like that first knock stuff to the
cool thing about them is that they'll be
there for that first knock but they stay
with the family for as long as the
family needs them until they say hey
we're good we got it from here so
educational support for the kids they do
retreats for the survivors they do
Goldstar retreats we're just the
children from you know
families that have lost a servicemember
they can come they have grief support
groups they have I mean everything from
dental supports medical bills I mean
it's it's invisible until you get a
knock on your door and it's the thing
that you absolutely need are they funded
properly they are funded and they're
funded 100% by the benevolence of the
American people so so people can give
we're go to Navy silver directly to the
Navy SEAL foundation website and it's a
you know they're very transparent
I think it's 96 cents out of every
dollar goes to the causes Wow four
percent to the overhead they have the
highest rating of any charity and it's
uh you know there's never going to be a
time I think I'm totally guessing but
there hasn't been a time since the
inception of this country where there
hasn't been people who have their toes
on the line somewhere in defense of what
we are trying to be and you know those
people are deserving of the support of
the American people when something
happens and that's you know that's one
of many organizations that you can go to
and support financially that will be
there when I mean just imagine having a
knock on the door first thing in the
morning getting ready to take your kids
out to school and there's four people
standing up from your house in uniform
and it it's I can't even describe it
that and and doing that as a job entail
you know that's got to be so there it is
Navy SEAL foundation a SEAL foundation
yep and then n Zeppelin yeah it's super
easy to find as Google Navy SEAL
foundation and again if that's not your
flavor give back to your firefighter
organization get back to a policing
organization I mean that's all again the
spokes on a wheel like there's
constantly people out there who are
invisible 99.9 percent of your life
until you need yeah [ __ ] you
all right thanks coming on this jambe
apocalypse please have your phone on
speed dial because I'll be calling you
not will be needing you maybe you guys
can work for me for your daily water
rafting deal and be like that oh yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah we well Andy gave me a
little I I came around the corner with
my fake gun and I which I read this
thing you know I use my head I guess I
looked around first and that was the
wrong thing to do don't lead with your
eyes guys yeah
all right good thanks so much Angela -
where's - great story yes for the party
kids we're out